an important point as it relates to the
buffalo bills one of the teams that
could derail
the kansas city chiefs the the the bills
may have
fans
in what is now known bill's stadium it's
gone from rich stadium to ralph wilson
stadium to new era field it's now bill's
stadium they're trying to finalize a
plan and get official approval for 7 000
people that's not a huge crowd but 7 000
crazy screaming bills fans is better
than zero and we're still waiting to
find out they want to wait and see what
the infection rates look like in early
january they have to make a decision
fairly quickly because they'll play a
game there most likely the weekend of
january the 9th but uh shireen uh
look those fans deserve this and i was
both impressed and also a little bit
horrified by the thousands that were
packed together
waiting at the airport i don't know how
you can stop a spontaneous celebration
like that is it smart amid a pandemic no
but what can you do what can you do yeah
you can't do anything mike those fans
deserve that hopefully kova didn't
sprang
crazy there their first playoff game
since january 1997 i hope they do get to
have fans in the stands but either way
that is a tough place to play in january
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports